le sébaste à la coloration qui va de
laurent jour où juifs se retrouvent dans
le pacifique ainsi que dans l'atlantique
nord mais ils avaient disparu de nos
assiettes depuis longtemps si j'allais
pêcher seul type qui ça arrive et
d'empoigné de 30 ans à l'occasion il ya
eu le moratoire seul aux 25m et sûr
lamoureux et il se bat ce ne serait pas
aisée chez lui si elle allait pas qui a
lui subi qu'un combat tel moratoire sont
mort union arrêté on essaie de protéger
la ressource dans les deux cas il ya des
populations et être offerts comme
l'amour unsa basse la même chose en 2018
pêches et océans canada lève
l'interdiction parce que l'espèce est
redevenu abondantes ces deux à trois
fois plus élevés que blow 30 à 35 et
mettons tout vrai deux fois plus tôt en
plus de ses bases il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup moi ça m'avait obligé le site a
vraiment l'impression à floirac cenon
rive creebec
jonathan lapierre chef du restaurant de
l'institut de tourisme et d'hôtellerie
du québec ne jure que par les produits
le court c'est donc avec grand intérêt
que ce passionné va cuire ce poisson à
chair blanche pour la première fois un
cliff laissant pauvres les retient à lui
le tournesol est qu un peu d'âge autour
chauffe-eau ça c'est sincèrement huile
sel un peu d'allant au fond après quatre
minutes prendre ces petits facile sa
garde écoutez-vous plus naturel ce
poisson aussi un petit peu moins gros
que pour reprendre le fil et je suis les
leçons et vu le tournesol resaler en
ôtant son châle d'euros pour vraiment
qu'une dispersion de chasse bien le chef
enveloppe le sébaste dans des algues du
chai laurent pour la cuisson les a
vraiment juste pour comme le bonifier
son goût mais ça se fait sans agde la
cuisson se fera dans un four préchauffé
à une température oscillant autour de
180 degrés celsius c'est à dire 3 175
degrés fahrenheit surtout les poissons
qui sont assez petits sismiques sont
assez réactive 80 % des tpe
jusque récemment sans peyras obtenu xoxo
égal de bar en bar
sur mes propres exactions les genres
comme ça recoupe affrontait 3000 m dames
empêcher la peau de se rétracter en
cuisante deuxième méthode sur la
cuisinière afin d'obtenir une peau
croustillante
le poisson est déposée côté peau dans
une huile assez chaude pour environ 95%
du temps de cuisson puis on tourne
rapidement sur son autre phase bon on va
découvrir sébastien heureux parce que on
sera pas de cachet ni toi ni moi n'avons
jamais goûté au c est vraiment évident
nous où on avait fait deux péchés semble
ok avec amp en petites bouchées de
poissons alors évidemment tout comme un
superman pas plus loin qui nous ouais ok
beaucoup plus noble que je pensais même
après décongélation le sébaste concert
d'une texture floconneuse similaire à
celle de l'amour chuck c'est de
découvrir plus sur le croustillant qui
est vraiment très accessible très
polyvalent ce très douce c'est une belle
texture s'appelle un poisson tous les
jours c'est sans se poser de questions
mais avant de le retrouver de façon
courante chez notre poissonnier
l'industrie devra vivre une période
d'adaptation
okada les usines pour la transformation
faut que le marché c'est là aussi qu'il
faut cada peau si les méthodes de paito
vont être modifiés pour laisser passer
des petits poissons
j'ai vraiment c'est juste le plus gros
pic pour avoir une pêche durable aussi
bonne nouvelle la pêche aux sébaste dans
le golfe est à nouveau certifié durable
par ocean wise
alors qu'est ce qu'on aime de l'idée du
ce basque accueille une nouvelle espèce
a permet je pense de postes acharné son
second cas l'alimentation je pense qu
intéressant on devrait graduellement
voir réapparaître le sébaste sur les
étals entier ou en filets demande est là
pour le découvrir vous aussi
[Musique]